ce soir emmanuel da qu'on avait pour
objectif d'être d'incarner le président
de la vérité eu beaucoup de choses qui
sont dites les dernières semaines il a
besoin d'abord de se clarifier et de
dire peut-être que aucun président est
très peu de présidents ont pu dire c'est
déjà reconnaître des erreurs reconnaît
les erreurs reconnaître peut-être un
manque de préparation et ça c'est assez
rare et c'est vrai que depuis quelques
temps que quelques semaines on on se
disait que c'était un ratage du
démarrage de cette excuse mais pourquoi
parce que bien entendu nous fallait pas
se manquer celle ci est la vie petit à
gc aurait nouveau oui allez vous parle
je parle et qu'il a reconnus et vous
parlez de il ya un instant il a reconnu
ses erreurs est ce que pense et c'est
une force où ça va être considérée comme
une faiblesse par ses adversaires aussi
non c'est une forme d'adieu n'oublions
pas que les erreurs dont on parle ne
sont pas du genre côté comique que par
le gouvernement mais par aussi une
succession j'appelle un cumul de cumul
de mandats et beaucoup d'erreurs
commises depuis quelques années mais
c'est bien un moment qu'on tournait un
grand chef il a été ce soir je trouve
qu'il a été plus que d'habitude il a été
créé des liens dans son expression
d'autres pensaient qu'ils allaient
plutôt au discours royal alors on vous
l'a dit c'est le père du tueur chilien
qui a pris franck tapiro en main et je
veux ce prêt bien assumé jeu ce qu'on
sait des infos qu'on a de nos
journalistes
sachez que ce soir justement il voulait
faire un discours très turquie lien
voilà c'est ce qu'il voulait faire avant
voilà et c'est ce qu'ils voulaient
c'était son objectif ce soir donc pour
vous objectif réussi oui réussit bien
sûr totalement remis parce que c'était
les français droit dans les yeux et je
pense qu'elle était très émouvant
surtout sur la fin aussi dont tout en
reconnaissant ses dévoila d'être celle
des nations qui propose des choses et
qui dit les choses surtout dire les
shows professeur annette vous on a
besoin d'avoir votre avis là dessus sur
ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état
forcément il est très important pour
nous votre votre avis professeur comment
vous l'avez trouvée et les annonces
qu'il a faites
est ce qu'elle vous
est ce qu'elle vous rassure ou pas du
tout les annonces ce qu'il a fait avant
tout dans le bon sens
respect du confinement pendant un mois
ça va nous permettre de reprendre notre
souffle nous réorganiser de mieux
structurer nos services pour accueillir
les malades qui vont arriver de manière
beaucoup plus progressive et donc on va
on va forcément vivre pendant un mois
une décroissance de la pression sur les
hôpitaux déconfinement à partir du 11
mai et déconfinement progressif il
annoncer quelque chose qui est très
important à mon sens et la réouverture
des écoles et ça c'est quelque chose de
fondamental
je pense qu'on vous prend aucun risque
en termes de santé publique
les enfants et toutes les études le
montrent vont une mentalité qui est
vraiment négligeable thouars nul sauf
s'ils sont en bonne santé de ce
coronavirus est donc cette cette
réouverture des écoles va permettre déjà
de faire redémarrer un petit peu la vie
tout simplement
les enfants c'est la vie avec avec des
musiques qui vont se remettent à
démarrer donc je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important et personnellement
c'est quelque chose que nous attendait
parce que les enfants aussi va vous
permettre si certains s'infecte
d'augmenter l'immunité de la population
il a annoncé deux choses importantes que
vous avez pas encore dit c'est
généralisation de la porte du masque
c'est un changement complet directement
au début rappelé mot disait les masques
seulement pour les soignants à tout le
monde à porter son masque et ça ça va
bien la progression du virus en
respectant les dix sensations physiques
mais aussi généralisation des tests
donc on va dans une logique comme en
allemagne où va généraliser les tests
mais il faut bien dire ce qu'on va faire
aussi comme un test positif
qu'est ce qui est prévu on va régler les
hôtels des gymnases pour les isoler
combien tous des mesures d'isolement qui
sont à prévoir si on généralise les
tests donc tout ça d'un point de vue
santé publique va dans le bon sens et je
pense qu'on avait besoin de ces quatre
semaines pour vraiment pour nous
hospitalier se préparer dans le calme
se voir ces niveaux passe